Disney uses a more vintage logo to
remind the audience that they have made
this movie before and are now ripping
off themselves this movie exists based
on this logo transition one can only
assume that Disneyland is the man
village many strange tales a toad of
this jungle mary shit a boy raised by
jungle creatures still feels compelled
to wear a giant red diaper mowgli almost
keeps up with his wolf brethren even
though they are wolf's and he is a human
child one of these days you'll be
someone's dinner it's amazing that he
hasn't already been someone's dinner it
was a dead tree because it looked dead
and you're like ten years old and should
have figured out the difference between
alive and dead
especially if you live in the jungle I
knew he needed of people the people to
protect him it's why I entrusted him to
the wolves
if bigger entrusted him to the wolves
then why is he always within paws reach
of Mowgli
that doesn't sound like Trust to me sped
up time-lapse video for the sake of mood
I guess the water true cuz a bald eagle
doing in the Indian jungle whoa don't
forget the truth I know the lower bucks
the water truce which is a big load of
crap by the way is a big load of crap
during the water truce is it also the
law that all direct predator and prey
enjoy the water right next to each other
or is that just for visual effect to
underscore the peace eNOS of these times
look at this green bacteria riddled
water they've all been drinking from
just look at it somehow the CGI tiger in
this movie looks even worse than the CGI
tiger in life upon there are multiple
wolves rhinos antelope and so on but
there was only one Panther one bear and
one sole tiger in this entire jungle I
think this movie was just an excuse to
test the bounds of modern CGI and as
such is a failure since that frog look
thicket who is giving mowgli haircuts
with banks and where is he getting the
shampoo and conditioner that keep his
hair from getting knotted up like
dreadlocks they deliberated and they
argued wolf Council of Elrond the Cohens
but why why not just eat him I wish I
could tell you that the Wolves could
have fought so calm but this is not that
kind of a tale so what you're telling me
is a pack of wolves couldn't take on one
tiger I find that hard to believe I'm
bringing you to the man village
you always said we're not supposed to go
near on me
village you always said stay away from
the men's oh Jesus this conversation
must have had some huge pauses to take
place in so many varied locales I mean I
agreed but I don't live in the jungle
shouldn't he be used to them by now the
elephants created this jungle how
because the jungle is no longer safe for
you you're being hunted by a tiger only
man can protect you now something tells
me the point of this movie is the exact
opposite of the statement what now ask
to bow to the Buffalo - that's racist
human child outruns African tiger
because of course he does obviously he
survives this like he's fucking Simba or
something Jesus it's like the Running of
the Bulls only 99 percent more dangerous
which only makes Mowgli survival here
that much more unbelievable
whew a movie are you trying to test how
many he survives this sins I'm willing
to write in a row challenge accepted no
that's morbol instead of chasing the
herd and mowgli from that not very cold
peak Shere Khan decides to just stand
here defeated watching all the water
buffalo and mowgli escape with ease I
mean he roars like he's angry but if he
was really angry he just jumped down and
kept chasing them so and when I asked
has he gone does this movie try any
harder than the animated classic to
explain why the tiger wants so badly to
kill Mowgli no no it does not
are you seriously trying to tell me this
many wolves couldn't defeat this one
tiger in a fight why don't they just
jump as Shere Khan straight up kills a
wolf but somehow that doesn't other
wolves do nothing thank God for this
rain avalanche so that Mowgli has a
chance to be separated from these water
buffalo and find Baloo basically follow
the original cartoon storyline I mean
honestly this is more deadly than any
fucking tiger after surviving a crazy
stupid fall down a rocky mountain Mowgli
will now Richard Kimble himself to
freedom because Mowgli is made of
play-doh and it's not actually human
god damn it now the movies ripping off
the foggy bomb from the neverending
story
well this dumb kid as the vertical leap
of a rhino did the wolves that raised
him skipped jump training lieutenant
John Dunbar and two socks called
they'd like their bit back please mow we
will yell this and chase after these
wolf baby things despite the fact that
he just lucked the fuck out in finding
this fruit and literally reached up
about one foot in the air to grab them
it's a jungle dude find some more fruit
don't wear yourself out chasing the
first batch of thieves you encounter
thieving wolf monkeys leave Mowgli
Street and tushy looms lair and I'm
instantly pissing my pants and wondering
if any of the elements of astoria
original I
you are I know where you came from well
then that means you know more than me or
this movie since we started out with him
as a man wolf with no real backstory as
to why also movie rips off the bad guy
lures in the good guy by promising
knowledge about his real family thing
from um I kind of think of a good
example right now this is a common thing
right am I crazy
Oh movie gets away with a colloquial
name for but that I was kicked out of
seventh grade social studies for using
means everything is man's fault course
and man and wouldn't regular old
Lightning have made fire on earth long
before man anyway this the traveler
protecting his God wait
Mowgli can see the God and this snake is
cooking magic why doesn't she just show
him something that will cause him to act
in a way that just ends this movie right
now this is actually the first time I
think I've seen Mowgli's back stories
such as it work
this still feels like I'm seeing Bruce
Wayne's parents murdered in an alley for
the tenth time Shere Khan ended the
man's life that night and then left
without eating the baby because he knew
this movie needed both a plot and a
villain with the past connection to that
plot he ran so fast he didn't notice the
cub he left behind what he was fighting
that dude in that cave for a good
several seconds and that cub was super
visible and obvious like he with this
noise just say he was so freaked out by
the I burning he ran off and then be
done with it no need to tell lies to
reinforce his retreat the entire jungle
book story animated or otherwise I
totally hinges on a killer black panther
deciding to take a fleshy piece of food
to the wolves for adoption instead of
eating it you can be with me if you want
I'll keep you close look Scarlett
Johansson said this to me snake or human
or otherwise I'd ask where I should sign
no line but Mowgli is way too young to
be swayed by sexiness so I'm calling
bull on the seductive crap he's like
nine years old you perverts because this
idiot snake took forever to wrap up
seduced and then eat this boy the Baloo
ex machina is able to save the day as ex
machina czar known to do you're kidding
me right movie character sends to Bill
Murray bear what I'm currently saying to
movie but I don't climb and you do if
Baloo doesn't climb then explain to me
how he got up into that tree to rescue
Mowgli from cop winners common discount
Nets darkest bear boat Lee's been raised
in the jungle or bees live but it's
utterly fooled by Baloo into going after
this behind are the wolves that raised
him just really can stupid a Mac of yeah
you believe it are you sure this goes on
for some time
these bees haven't swarmed Mowgli and
stung him 10,000 times at this point Pig
looking yes blue is having a ridiculous
conversation with Mowgli right now but
my main concern is that Mowgli is still
wiping honey all over his bee stings
based on Baloo's lies a few minutes ago
behad has yet to feel any bodily
sensations at the sight of these bee
stings that would communicate to him
that he's literally pouring sugar on
open wounds I'll take you there myself
come on let's go it's getting late
Mowgli blindly trust the bear that just
blatantly lied to him about the bees and
the stinging and the whatnot he wisely
cuts away before we see blues answer to
this question from I don't know kids
that look familiar I don't remember it
all I remember is living with the wolves
why would you remember anything prior to
being a baby
the scene is tense and all but another
did share khan somehow week and lore all
but one of the wolf pups up this nearby
mountain in the middle of the night
without waking any of the adult wolves
why did the wolf cubs even listen to
this obvious predator I don't want em
dead just like in the cartoon Shere Khan
is a super unhealthy fixation on killing
the man-cub which threatens him exactly
0% home alone the jungle condition okay
I don't love this movie as a whole but
this playful bear necessities float down
the river scene is fun and touching and
I'm gonna go ahead and take a sit on
just one though let's not get crazy here
[Music]
to be fair you looked in one place and
then almost got eaten by a snake and
then stop looking altogether Mowgli is
going to sneak away from the two
individuals that care about it simply
because they disagree with each other or
maybe he just really wanted to glimpse
the elephants
either way Mowgli is stupid how many gun
makes it four oaks that he can make dude
and win not any special I raised him but
what about the wolves I'm so confused I
don't even care anymore can you just
skip to the CGI ending already Shere
Khan killed him he was stopped at
nothing until he has this boy again how
does one nine-year-old man-cub become
this bigger threat to the jungles
greatest predator why does he hate
Mowgli seemingly more than he hates
auricular or don't men from the man
village the only way we can save him is
if he goes to that man village but why
can you explain that even one time I
don't want you around anymore
Blu and see no-man's and Harry and the
Hendersons Mowgli also is it just me or
did Baloo just do a complete 180 he was
telling back here nah man let the kid be
whoever he wants to be like minutes ago
then Mowgli saves a baby elephant in all
the Sun Blues all convinced the kid
needs to be sent home look these two
adult caretakers once again let this
helpless child get into danger simply by
not paying attention
Bagheera and Baloo pink sucked as
babysitter's man OH
we found the crystal school alien temple
everybody wrong also somehow the
building CGI looks faker than the animal
CGI go figure
Balu is totally a discount PO from Kung
Fu Panda but whatever I'm done with this
movie at this point flower how did these
coincidentally English speaking jungle
animals come to call fire the red flower
because it grows super fast at Detroit
because it's so hot because it is orange
and not red why tarnish the reputation
of all the actual red flowers in the
jungle with this misnomer there's one
thing I don't have and that's the one
thing you can give me the red flower
Louie is fixated on getting the red
flower even though he could easily rule
over the jungle by simply being the
largest creature it just sit on Shere
Khan and that would be the end of it
when I desire his man's red five here's
the second of the film's forced musical
connections to the original animated
film only unlike the last one this one
isn't endearing or even plot important
and ends up feeling like Christopher
Walken just has a must sing a song
clause in his contract these days let me
interrupt myself I just gotta say you
guys so much handsomer in person movie
gives Bill Murray way to many seconds of
free time to just Bill Murray for a bit
and then animate around that for some
reason wow that worked movie revives the
old sneaked away while someone else
lectures the bad guy routine and I'm
almost as impressed as I am bored out of
two modern Apes movies get Apes CGI so
right but this movie comes close to
reminding me of Jumanji how much of this
budget we'll spend on the one human
actor because it's starting to feel like
way too much haha try being the
operative word
considering there are 600 of them too
many seconds of these two heroes beating
monkey ass even though it's boring and
useless to the story and also hard to
believe considering the sheer number of
monkeys think about it man-cub we can
rule this jungle this is just like the
end of the first Transformers movie when
Megatron is chasing Sam and taunting it
except somehow and despite all on so the
transformer scene is more entertaining
than this one thank God for Mowgli this
soft landing tree was right outside the
well and cares anymore King Louie has
been hoisted by his own petard
because the animals lied to him about
his wolf dad dying Mowgli runs right
back to the man village that he's never
known as a home or a safe zone or even
known at all makes sense
jeez that is an unwieldy fire the wonder
all the animals are scared of the red
flower the humans build giant fires that
are clearly hard to control instead of
seeking his true lineage or man answers
Mowgli actually only a return to the man
village to steal fire because he wanted
to go for a night run and he's a huge
Olympic Games fan like
more than two minutes of him running
with a torch every single animal in the
jungle will be present for the big
finale of this movie well I will be
asleep despite chanting together a
moment ago these animals all let the
bear fight the tiger on his own because
they're a bunch of chickens share count
somehow lasts more than five seconds in
this fight against a thousand jungle
analysts you know why you rarely see the
kid and the tiger together in one shot
in the scene because rumor has it the
two actors hated each other on set and
by the end of filming could barely even
acknowledge each other's existence so
they had to film their scenes separate
from one another true story how long did
you really think you'd survive against
me honestly I thought the bear friend
alone would have been good for like ten
years and that's not counting the
leopard friend and all the wolves either
own Daniel father did his dad comment
gives Mowgli pause even though he never
knew his father and totally bonded the
back era and Baloo in this movie way
more than he did his adopted wolf father
and after all that man-cub both the
animals in this jungle finally decided
to work together on cleaning up the god
er the elephants were able to divert
enough water to basically put out this
entire forest fire in an instant than
all the jungle together for the very
first time and all the predatory animals
went hungry and then extinct as this
bull next time on Mowgli is an ignorant
dick jungle races
you
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio out takes once more into
the fray into the last good fight I'll
ever know we'll be back at the end of
the season when the last leaf falls if I
got your attention now good because
we're adding a little something to this
month's sales contest as you all know
first prize is a Cadillac Eldorado
anybody want to see second prize second
prize a set of steak knives hello I'm
here
I didn't just survive a wreck I wasn't
just blown up yesterday I have been
stabbed shot poisoned frozen home
electrocuted and burned
[Music]
I'm Sicilian my father was the world
heavyweight champion of Sicilian Liars
from growing up with him I learned the
pantomime there are 17 different things
a guy can do when he lies to give
himself away guys got 17 Panther -
woman's got 20 guys got 17